here's a little thing I want to do
called what's in my bag because I've had
these celebrity makeup artists come in
and I'm like I want to know everything
and I've been watching things and people
I'm like I want you guys to see what's
in these people's bags so tell me what
are some of your favorite things that
you have with you my favorite is the
lemare translucent setting powder this
is my go to finding a good translucent
powder is really hard so this is great
for all skin types the only time I
wouldn't really recommend it is if it's
for really if you have really oily skin
okay it might not be enough for you but
it has a little bit of an iridescent and
then this Tom Ford bronzer this one is
gold dust there's a few different colors
this one's my favorite
it is massive can I touch it yeah that's
pretty I use that as an eyeshadow base
and yeah and it has an iridescent stat
to it seems
yep it does so it's not completely matte
yes it's a good color because bronzers
you can look orange they really have to
be careful with that and then the
highlight this one yeah this is iconic
London
it's the liquid highlighter and this is
the original so they have a few
different colors but this one's my
favorite so it really gives you that
glowy dewy look yeah photograph stuff
only so swatch little bit on me and then
oh lightly like dab it and it's Joe look
at that oh my god that's beautiful
thanks for sharing of course